the roar of power tools could be felt
throughout the campus of unlv this
morning the entire rebel athletic
program was busy building beds for kids
in need the pieces of 98 beds were built
for sleep and heavenly peace a charity
that fundraises builds assembles and
delivers beds all over las vegas
athletic director eric harper arrived on
campus at 6 a.m and led by example sue
and the football team came and then the
volleyball soccer swimming and cheer
squads they partnered with generous
donors and built the headboards inside
railings it was a ton of work a ton of
dust but truly a labor of love i am so
proud of our student athletes and their
initiative and what they've done today
our football team got here it's before 7
a.m and started the project
the volleyballs here women's basketball
soccer cheer dance uh all of our student
athletes have been here uh those that
are in town have been here
to support this project and i you know
as an athletic director i can't be more
proud of them than i am today
because they're giving back